I would like to say that once again
through the magic of modern electronics
we go to New York weather permitting
weather permits Jerry and the Academy
permits me the pleasure of introducing a
brilliant artist who is herself a
contender for the Best Actress Award for
her remarkable performance in the bad
seed Miss Nancy Kelly
hi Jerry and so you look very lovely in
radiant thank you very much Jerry indeed
would you like to read the awards I
would like to very much I'm about as
anticipate Horry about this as you are
and we start the nominees for the Best
Actor in a supporting role our Don
Murray and bus-stop Anthony Perkins in
friendly persuasion Anthony Quinn and
lust for life
Nicky Rooney in the bold and the brave
and Robert Stack and written on the wind
and may I have the envelope please thank
you in Hollywood
the winner is Anthony Quinn for luck
ladies and gentlemen
needless to say I'm deeply moved at the
risk of being misunderstood
I want to humbly say to my fellow
nominees that acting has never been a
matter of competition to me I want to
say that I was only competing with
myself and I thank you very much for
letting me win that fight over myself